husbands hate him for this one simple
trick leaving your wife at the
restaurant
[Music]
um so a dude in Thailand has uh kind of
gotten himself in the doghouse uh oh
after with this Taiwan I love that term
by the way with his Thai wife yeah yeah
with his Thai wife was he wearing a dog
costume and [__] jerking off inside
of it
um no close guess but different culture
different culture
basically uh they like fighting and
coconuts
basically they're on a road trip
um they stop by for a toilet break wife
uses a toilet man forgets that she's in
the toilet he bounces and she has to
walk 12 miles to catch up 12 miles wait
how does he forget and just drive
without that's [__] for 12 miles not
buying it this is the part where you
guys riff
that's crazy that she has to walk 12
miles when you tell me a time he [__]
forgot where Nina was yeah uh I don't
think I messed up that bad at 12 months
they weren't fighting I will say there
was definitely a time where you know
you're just kind of like having a bunch
of fun it's like a night out everybody's
like you know moving to the next place
whatever right and I remember we like
ran over to get into the elevator before
it closed all of us were like running uh
made it in slammed the door huh yeah
we're good right but Nina didn't make it
yet but I was just so ecstatic that I
ran fast and made into elevator you're
gonna try to stick your fingers no
honestly I just got shocked she was like
what the heck and it just closed and I
was like oh [__] I'm in the dog house
tonight you know you like get it to the
floor but like you're not even enjoying
the elevator item there I'm like I'm
hoping she comes up this exact same
elevator I'm gonna get it right now and
that was all it really was I got in
trouble but did you ask her I told you
you should have trained running yeah
that's right run faster that's right
yeah later I should have been blaming
her for that you should you should go it
always works and then they go you know
what you're right and then they start
running and then they get better at you
at running and then now you are the last
one at the elevator and they look back
and they go ah chop yeah
I'm sure I probably messed up harder
than that but for my own
self-preservation on social media dude
leaving leaving your wife or then
driving off for 12 miles that's a long
time [__] dude you're going 60 miles
an hour where was she sitting previous
that he didn't realize the only place he
could be going to is to build his own
dog house
okay let's say the gas station is in
their like neighborhood like they're
like walking distance to their house or
whatever right let's go let's just find
this let's just let's just let's just
say he's filling up gas right he goes
pee he comes back he his wife leaves
he's like she's always at the market and
he's like he left
because in his mind she's like go always
going to the market that's like right
she's a Wanderer you know this was a
road trip and it was it was in the
middle God damn
dude this is pretty meditative basically
what was happening
yeah that guy's like yo I'm gonna go
home and like she can call me I'll pick
her up yeah we'll be back in like four
hours yeah there's no way or what if she
takes like monster shits and it takes
forever
so he's like I'm gonna Circle back I
don't even understand how you come out
of this situation looking like it was an
accident yeah they went they didn't just
they weren't fighting no no they were
just driving through the night to spend
some time in her hometown in the
province of Maha so the trip is about
her
yeah and then around 3 A.M uh the guy
decided to pull over to relieve himself
she uh she asked me it was at 3am too
she asked her husband why he hadn't
stopped at a petrol station uh that they
recently passed when he didn't answer
she decided to see the chance of a
toilet break and she also hopped out of
the car she ducked into the jungle to
pee but when she ventured back onto the
road uh the road was empty the car and
her husband were both gone and she'd
been left alone on a rural roadside in
the middle of the night with no money or
phone so she naturally had to walk uh
this guy's gay
think about it he's on the middle of the
road and then he's like all right oh
[__] there's a [__] hot spot of a
rest stop coming up oh yeah I'll like
pretend like I forgot my wife and he's a
sea bass freaking yeah dude he's in
there getting be here at 212 or manly
loving some [__] and then he's like oh
what I forgot that's the three knocks
and then the penis comes through the
line take this guy's gay he's so funny I
legit think he's gay or the comment
about how convenient that's what I'm
saying that was the giveaway right there
yeah how come you stop at the picture
okay yeah yeah well that's the giveaway
and then [__] dip you can see the nag
in the dialogue right there it's the nag
dude dude 3 A.M is rough he was hoping
that she wouldn't find him oh check this
out yeah he was hoping that because
because the poor woman walks 12 and a
half miles before she reaches uh uh the
District of whatever around 5 a.m local
police have tried to help her get in
touch with her oblivious husband but uh
she couldn't remember his phone number
she calls her phone number they said
they called her at least 20 times he
never answered finally at 8 AM police
made contact with her husband and he
turned around but by that time he was
160 kilometers away dude did it on
purpose it's not an accident
160. he did it on purpose huh yeah
because like what that's what I'm saying
like if she was in the passenger seat
how do you not know he said apparently
he said he thought his wife had been
asleep in the back seat the entire time
that sounds [__] yeah I know a lot
at the same time I also know some dudes
are just dumb as [__] too he might just
be both
he might just be dumb as [__] there's no
way he didn't know nah he was trying to
like leave her ass he was trying to 12
miles to you this [__] is fuming every
mile she's like saying more [__] she's
like preparing her [__] speech this
guy's dead
is he alive right now
School thinks his wife is like a child
that can't find him so yeah
dude Andy called her phone 20 times 12
miles is a long time to walk with luck
it seems like one of those things where
he was pissed at her and wanted to do
this to her and knew she would
eventually come back but then he would
go oh I forgot dude what if he actually
came back and he's like oh [__] where
the [__] is she
and then and then and then he's like he
couldn't find her and he's like [__]
what am I gonna
keep driving 160 kilometers obviously
the only way this checks out is if
there's a dash cam facing front and he's
having a conversation the whole time and
then eventually goes what do you think
honey I guess you're asleep whatever and
he keeps calling you
why don't you pick up the phone oh the
silent treatment huh I see what's
happening
27 years and have a son who's 26 years
old oh [__] but hates this woman yeah
he's gay husbands hate him for this one
simple trick leaving your wife at the
rest stop
all right so I just hate it hot take if
you were to leave your wife how would
you do it I'd probably do it a similar
way because Tiff doesn't know my phone
number either
oh oh and that hurts my feelings she
doesn't know your phone number yeah and
I want to fight her sometimes you guys
don't have at least memorized for safety
reasons I know her number but she
doesn't know yours because she's a jerk
she mean bro it's a Salvadorian thing
what happened I take it personally
that's what I'm saying she's on her
phone and I tell her and every time I'm
like you know my number is I make her I
try to quiz her she's so [__] yeah
dude and that's too resourceful but I
think she's getting better I think she
got of course she subscribes dude yeah
she watches the show she left her phone
in my in my car and then um she like I
was like I was gone and then I get a
call from jumbi and I was like who's
calling me right now and then I'm like
hello and then it was my nephew and he's
always like Hannah wants you to go back
and pick her up because the phone's in
your car she'll be at the Coffee Bean
and I'm like all right and then I'm
talking and then it's he already hung up
and I'm like all right [__] I'm going
back that's Resort she was hanging out
what were you gonna say that's
resourceful you're gonna say after your
nephew stopped talking
is this like an interstitial do you got
um between videos I was like where what
Japan there's a guy the nephew's just
like
he already knows the [__] protocol I
know the pattern [__] I'm gonna got it
he breaks his back
throws the SIM card out breaks it
the burner phone Joe's Japan burner
phone no what she did is she used their
phone to call the store phone to talk to
them at the store to tell me oh she used
coffee bean to call June B to call you
oh that is classic Brit yeah classic
Brit before me and Nikki were engaged I
was following her to the Honda
dealership because she was getting her
car serviced but then I didn't bring my
phone for some [__] reason and then
Nikki is a Lead Foot and and I'm a much
slower driver than her and so I just saw
her just like take off into the distance
and I get stopped at red and I was like
Nikki I don't know where the [__] the
dealership is I don't have my phone
either because I was just gonna follow
her the whole way and she's lead footing
it the whole way with [__] Eminem
playing I'm sure and so then I totally
she totally smokes me so I'm like [__] I
don't know how to I don't can't call her
so so I pulled over at a subway and I
was like hi can I use your internet and
they're like what the [__] and they gave
me this iPad and I was able to because I
don't know Nikki's [__] number like I
like the same [__] I don't I'm not a
number well that was back then before we
were engaged I was like I only just
clicked the number on my click the name
on my phone so then I was like oh [__]
so I emailed her dad because I knew her
dad's email I remember this story yeah
and then he and then I was like yo can
you call call Nikki and tell her that
she smoked me and I don't know where the
[__] the dealership is and then he he
did he got his because her dad's like
the most anal dude I've ever known like
he's an accountant the email pops up
he's replying immediately on it so like
that was actually pretty good call
because then you know I was able to find
out yeah
oh
[Music]
foreign